when I was a wee lad a young man I lived
on fifteen hundred dollars a month and
believe it or not during that period of
time while splitting a room sleeping on
the floor with another dude I was taking
home about fifteen twenty thousand
dollars a month and the reason that I
lived like that is because hey I'm
incredibly risk-averse but B because I
wanted to have money to go on the
offensive later if you don't know I am
my name is I own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies it's over 200
million a year and I have nothing to
sell you I make these videos because I
want you to make shitloads of money and
make a big company so that someday we
can partner together and take it to 100
million dollars and beyond for me making
20 grand a month was never an amount of
money that I wanted to brag about or
feel like I had made it I wanted to
shoot really really big this was only
stuff that was going to be stepping
stones for me to achieve what I wanted
to later what I want to do in this video
is I'm going to break down how I was
able to live for so cheap this is for
all the single guys all the single
ladies now if you can live with your
parents even better for me somebody
would have died it was for the best that
I didn't have to live at home this is
what I actually did in order to live at
1500 a month or less and I did that
eating out every day there's three big
cost centers you got Transportation you
got living and you got food so food wise
some of you guys have seen Mosey meals
meal hacks the things that I do at these
chain restaurants and I did it that way
because I don't like cooking and I
wanted to have more time to make money
but made more financial sense for me to
not take eight hours on the Sunday to go
grocery shopping and prep all my food
versus me getting Chipotle twice a day
which is what I did at the time then 15
a day today 20 bucks a day 30 days in a
row 600 a month you can also go to Panda
Express which has a phenomenal 110 gram
of protein hacked with extra chicken so
you can have 200 grams of protein every
day recommend it third best option is
Chick-fil-A is one of my favorites they
are on the pricier side just go with a
220 packs of chicken nuggets and get in
close to 12 bucks this is a shitload of
meat or two sandwiches either way you'll
end up in that 10 to 12 range and you'll
be at that 600 700 a month range and if
you're like huh did he really do that I
sure did that's all I did I picked
between Chick-fil-A Panda Express and
chipotle and that's what I lived on so
much to this point that Layla didn't
know that we were going on dates but for
me these were the fine establishments
that I was frequenting on a regular
basis they knew me by name and they knew
that I knew how to work the menu so
first step was Mosey meals and that for
me time to money wise was worth it when
I would go to the grocery store and I
would get all the fixings and all the
stuff I spent 150 in a week and I ended
up spending almost 600 a month as a
single guy when I went grocery shopping
and did all the prep and all the clean
versus me running out next door grabbing
the food eating it and heading back and
it was a nice mental break for me I ate
cheap and as crazy as this may seem it
is easier to figure out how to get all
of your calories in eating out stuff
ahead of time the absolute cheapest
route which I'll tell you right now
loaves of bread peanut butter
cheapest thing in the world and if you
really want to make sure that you're
covering your basis get a multi item you
can live on it if you want to add a
third Staple in there you can add
Lactaid milk if you're Dairy sensitive
you'll get your protein you'll get your
carbs you get your fat in if you want to
be extreme on it you can be extreme for
me I didn't want to live on peanut
butter sandwiches I did eat them when I
was trying to bulk up but I did those in
addition to my normal calorie intake and
to that degree you might want to do one
of those Mosey meals and then do peanut
butter and milk is the other one which
is a nice cheap in between the reason
this is so important for everybody who's
watching this you got to know how to
live cheap so you can save up to build
the business you want so you can invest
in the skills and the experiences that
are going to make you money number two
is transportation this is where MOSI
mobiles came in there's lots of M's when
it comes to mobiles meals and mansions
from the mobile standpoint the most
efficient way to own a vehicle is to
purchase it in cash a used vehicle that
is ideally between 5 and 10 years old
any place in America right now today you
can find a used four-door vehicle that
is between 5 and 10 years old for 10 000
dollars you don't have car payments the
only thing you really have to manage is
car insurance which is not too expensive
and here's the cool part the cheaper
your car less the insurance you are
young and you are living on 600 a month
for Mosey meals and you live on a
hundred dollars a month after you've
made your one-time Capital expense of
actually getting the car which I
recommend doing and not taking a loan
for it all you have is your Mansion your
Chateau where are you going to rest your
head at night I lived in Southern
California one of if not the most
expensive markets in the United States I
was in Costa Mesa was where I lived and
after I slept on the floor of my gym
which is the first place which
technically was Zero but at the same
time it was five thousand dollars a
month because it was my actual rent for
my business I then really splurged I
ended up having a member at my gym say
are you really sleeping here said I sure
am another member was having me sleep at
their place for free I was able to move
from the free place to my own place
which is really in quotes here we split
a single bedroom in a seven bedroom
house key and I were roommates not
housemates roommates and I I had one
mattress that I got off Craigslist and
put on the floor fan next to my face
because it's really loud by the way so
you can not have to hear what someone
else is doing because every other
bedroom had a couple there were three
dogs in the house my roommate had a dog
another couple had a dog and another
couple had a dog and one of the couples
had two dogs and they were both big so
there was marking of territory there was
[ __ ] and piss in the house every day
it's [ __ ] horrible my half was 400
bucks a month if you're in like North
Carolina or you're in Boise Idaho you
can probably get a room for 400 a month
without having to split it big picture
here I would recommend you go to the
place where shit's happening 400 a month
that you'd spend to be in an area where
things are going on and people are doing
things with their lives to get out of
your area of the world where nothing's
happening and your friends are still in
the same place and your parents don't
encourage you and think this internet
[ __ ] is weird to tell you to stop
watching videos on YouTube and trying to
better yourself and just tell you to get
a job whatever it is if you want to get
out of that environment it is worth the
200 to 400 a month the easiest thing to
do is to to connect with people online
join communities join Discord groups
join Facebook groups whatever it is try
and figure out where there are pockets
of them because people congregate you
can find pockets of people that have
similar goals to you and get around them
every move for the first few years of my
career was only to be around people as
long as you're a person who's going to
hustle and people see it people will
open doors for you move from SoCal to
Puerto Rico briefly from there we move
to Irvine and then Albuquerque New
Mexico because I had people there that I
wanted to learn from and I didn't know
anyone else besides this one couple if
you just say hey do you know anybody
else who lives in this area and this is
where like now the world's even more
connected than it was a decade ago see a
lot in SoCal you see a lot in Miami
you'll see a lot of New York a lot of
Chicago and a big thing here if you see
Cleveland rich is not the same as SoCal
rich not the same as New York happens is
your standard of Excellence raises in
some ways you feel worse about yourself
but to the same degree it shows you
what's possible my recommendation is to
use that as inspiration it is possible
they're made of the same flesh and bone
as I am therefore I can too and when you
get around people like that they start
talking at different time increments and
different money increments if you're
hanging out with or talking in terms of
weeks talk in terms of paychecks talking
in terms of of 100
000 Investments you got to be talking to
people who are talking about hundred
thousand dollar Investments we're
talking about years talk about decades
you can judge
how wealthy people will be by how they
talk about how they allocate resources
time and money and the increments that
they measure those I've moved a lot
faster in life through handshakes
instead of hacks so who who introduced
me and opened way more doors than any
what ever did getting around the who a
lot of times it's hard to measure but
when I look at all the big deals that
I've done in my life it's all been one
or two degrees connected from people
that I met one recommendation that I
have for you don't turn down the first
invite you connect with somebody at a
thing it's like hey let's grab dinner if
you make that first one happen the
likely that you end up staying friends
and connecting is significantly higher
if you turn down the first invite it
shows that you're not as interested they
also turned out your counter invite and
it becomes this whole thing and I'm just
saying like one big move is just make it
work on the first invite when you go to
that meeting do some prep work do 30
minutes of research on the person you're
going to meet with and try to bring
something valuable to the table now it
might be your skill and you just apply
it to them and this is the thing this is
a [ __ ] hack a life no one wants a
free pass audio like hey you got a buddy
who builds patios you don't have a patio
you have a couple people bid for it your
buddy's like hey I'll build it for you
right he says he'll do it for free and
you say sure cool I'll save some money
the other guy said they can do it in
four weeks he starts taking four weeks
and it's you know a third of the way
down he said oh sorry I'm working on
some other jobs he'll be around to work
on it later this weekend and now it's
eight weeks and it's still you know
halfway done and at 12 weeks now you
start to [ __ ] hate the guy the thing
is is that if you want to do somebody a
favor if you really want them to take it
as a favor blow them away make them feel
awkward for the amount of work that you
did and if you've never had this
experience I can promise you I've been
on the receiving end and it is
uncomfortable [ __ ] I owe this guy
something and the nice thing about this
you just provide value you go in and you
know just probably a little bit of value
you actually do what a full-scope
project would be for whatever it is that
you're good at and you just set it up
for the dude or you spend a whole day
walking them through how you do this
stuff you're like well how do you find
the time for that you work all the time
that's how you do it this is work it's
investing in the long-term relationships
they're gonna pay to visit later does
that mean that I'm going to give to
somebody and I might not get anything
back yes didn't you say you want to be
an entrepreneur and make the world a
better place that's what it looks like
at a micro level the ultimate leverage
that you can have in a relationship is
not needing anything back if you do that
you can be the guy that stacks ious and
then when you do need to make your move
because you are going to do the next
thing then you've got all these blank
checks ready to cash in and then that is
how you can Propel yourself way faster
and you just load the deck early when
you don't need anything the time to dig
the well is not when you're thirsty but
when you have enough water so that when
you are thirsty it's there now we can go
on the offensive my plan B was always
strip at night drive Uber during the day
and I'm dead serious if you're making
less than 60 70 000 a year I don't
understand why you wouldn't take that
car that you saved up for that's got
four doors it's 15 years or younger and
has no visible damage on it if you got
those three check marks you can drive
Uber it is the most flexible job you can
make money immediately there's no risk
besides the actual vehicle itself you
can work whatever hours you want want
you can do it on separate apps and when
I say whatever hours I said there's
flexibility but also how many hours you
want you work 12 hours a day if you feel
like it living on 1500 bucks a month or
less spend 20 make another 200 have
saved up after taxes so I could go on
the offensive again if you know it
doesn't cost you much to live
your risk tolerance goes up because you
don't have other [ __ ] to worry about
real cost of the [ __ ] that you can't
afford or shouldn't be affording right
now you're paying for the car but you're
sacrificing your dreams you're paying
for going out with the boys at the club
buying a table getting bottle service
buying girls drinks all of a sudden boom
100 bucks boom 200 bucks in a night like
what just happened I was half my rent
you become less dangerous because it's
very hard to fight someone who has
nothing to lose
and it's very hard to find someone
who can live on nothing if we had to
pick between living on ten thousand
dollars a month and making ten thousand
dollars a month or living on fifteen
hundred dollars a month and then
spending the spread if you spend five
thousand dollars a month three thousand
dollars a month two thousand dollars a
month on your education so that you can
increase your earning capacity
it's hard to be stopped side note if you
can get competitive with yourself at how
little you can spend recommend one of
the other hacks that Dave Ramsey has
that I'm a huge fan of is taking out the
amount of money that you're gonna spend
for the entire month putting in your
wallet and leaving it there don't spend
more than that period that's it that's
all you got you're one of these people
who wants to credit card hack you'll get
two percent here and I get one percent
here and I get three percent here you're
focusing on the wrong [ __ ] percentage
side if you're trying to be financially
disciplined just [ __ ] be disciplined
so I get asked a lot about the income to
spending ratio I never had one that's
because I just try to maximize both
sides how can I hack the game to spend
as little as humanly possible period and
then how can I hack the other side of
the game make as much money as I
possibly can I just saved every dollar
that was in food Transportation living
the other way of doing this is getting
competitive with your bank account one
of the habits that I highly encourage
you do is that every morning what's the
first thing you check is it Instagram
is it YouTube is it your text I will
tell you the first thing that I checked
the mornings when I was in this period
of my life it was my bank account every
day I would wake up and I'll check my
bank account and what happens when you
do that is you develop this muscle of
kind of this understanding of the money
flow it might be uneventful to check
your bank account every day but if I can
give you a habit that will make you a
lot of money it's just like weight loss
if you get on a scale every day and
you're trying to lose weight and you
don't do jack [ __ ] but you literally
just get on the scale every day people
lose weight drawing and putting
awareness to the problem or the thing
that you're trying to change improves it
if you're in a business and you want
sales to go up start tracking everything
if you just start reporting publicly on
close rates and put a leaderboard up
sales go up think about this from a
human behavior standpoint punish bad
behavior with yourself as quickly as
possible and you want to reward good
behavior as fast as possible so you do
more of it that's why you check the bank
account every day start seeing it go up
and you get this little ticker it goes
up and if you really want to be a g
about it this is how I did it check your
bank account and you have a Google sheet
on your phone and every day I put my
balance in and if you can start getting
addicted to getting personal records in
your bank account like if I can give you
the one gift of this is to gamify it the
people who make the most money they
think about money as a game and the best
way to do that is early on track two
things you check your bank account and
you put it in and what's nice there is
that you can start seeing long-term
trends when I would look at that Trend I
got a tremendous amount of Good Feeling
I would look at it and be like I [ __ ]
did that and every month it get a little
bit bigger a little bit bigger a little
bit bigger and you start feeling
progress for the sacrifices that you
make every day because you look at where
you're at this month versus last month
and you see progress so if you want to
improve your money situation you got to
check it got to look at it every day and
the first thing in the day priority it
means it is happening prior it's more
important so you wake up you make money
a priority you check your bank out every
day you start get a pulse on what's
going in and what's going out what's
going in what's going on you look at all
of the pluses that go in you look at all
the minuses and next month you try to
make that column go up and that column
go down you keep running that cycle and
and I promise you if you actually look
at your bank account every single day
even for 90 days 90 days you will be
amazed at what goes in there they're
like huh didn't even know I still had
that app most people get anxiety they
avoid the things that they don't like
gotta confront it I'm [ __ ] poor don't
want to be poor I'm going to look at
this money until eventually it starts
paying attention back to me because
money sticks to the person who pays it
the most attention this is how the
economy works the person in two parties
who pays the most attention is where the
money ends up